You know, you look at the dystopian,
dystopian worlds.
One of the elements of it is everyone is frozen in their place.
Socialist countries, communist countries. There are rich people.
They're powerful people. What you don't see as new rich people,
what you don't say. You know,
when my dad in 1957 was a teenage kid from Cuba,
couldn't speak English, washing dishes, making 50 cents an hour.
Why did he come to America?
Because this is a country where you could be a teenage kid,
washing dishes and climb the,
that socioeconomic ladder and kind of worked out for his kid.
It, if someone had told my father in 1957,
that 50 years in the future,
his son would be in the Senate that teenage immigrant
could never have believed. And, and that,
but if we can have conversations, then we can say, all right, what works?
What doesn't work?
The left is afraid to have those conversations. Their ideas don't work.
Let's push a little further on this. So,
because the left wants to use state power in a way that
generally speaking the right doesn't want to,
or at least that you don't want to,
if we're to go on this dystopian future idea,
are you worried that if these guys really take power, I mean,
they're going to start jailing political opponents. They are going to use,
we know they've already used the IRS to do all sorts of crazy things. I mean,
these are things that are sort of conspiracy theories.
And then suddenly at this point, nothing feels like a conspiracy theory.
But it's all justified in the end.
There's a self-righteousness to it. We're right.
Anyone who disagrees is evil,
therefore anything is justified to suppress the evil.
You see that with cancel culture where people go like
get driven out out of the public discourse. Look,
w when I was in college, I was a college debater. Yes,
I was one of the cool kids.
But so I was in college. I was the,
the chairman of the conservative group in, in the debate debate society. And,
and w one of my closest friends was the head of the liberal group.
And we would have arguments about free enterprise and socialism,
like what works, what actually benefits humanity.
And actually that question is an important question
too often. People start with the assumption.
The other side wants humanity to suffer. If we start with the premise,
okay,
most people of Goodwill would like people to be happier and more well off
and more prosperous. We start with that premise.
Then we can have a conversation about what systems
produce more prosperity, more opportunity. It's it's, you know,
couple of years ago, I did three CNN town hall debates with Bernie Sanders and,
and they were 90 minutes long. And Bernie looked to Bernie's credit.
He's an unabashed socialist. I disagree with him, but he's honest.
And we can have a conversation about, you know, socialism.
I think if you look across the world, it doesn't work.
It's produced misery poverty, suffering, death. Um,
you know, my family fled Cuba.
And so I'm more than happy to take the American free enterprise system,
or as the left derisively calls it capitalism and put it up next to
communism or socialism or any dictatorship they've implemented in every,
any country on earth. And people are better off. They have more opportunity.
And, and in particular, there's the mobility. You know,
you look at the dystopian, um,
the Stopes in worlds,
one of the elements of it is everyone is frozen in their place.
Socialist countries, communist countries. There are rich people.
They're powerful people. What you don't see as new rich people,
what you don't see. You know,
when my dad in 1957 was a teenage kid from Cuba,
couldn't speak English, washing dishes, making 50 cents an hour.
Why did he come to America?
Because this is a country where you could be a teenage kid,
washing dishes and climb the,
that socioeconomic ladder and kind of worked out for his kid. It,
if someone had told my father in 1957,
that 50 years in the future,
his son would be in the Senate that teenage immigrant
could never have believed. And, and, and that, but if we can have conversations,
then we can say, all right, what works? What doesn't work?
The left is afraid to have those conversations, their ideas don't work.
All right. There, there's a joke that I tell sometimes, which is
how many radical leftists does it take to screw in a light bulb?
That's not funny, guys. Just relax, like,
like, like lighten up. And, and, you know,
I was talking about in college when we were debating, we'd go, you know,
I, he called me a fascist, I'd call him a, uh,
a communist. Then we could get a beer. Like just, you know,
not all of life has to be, I must destroy my enemy. And there's a lot of that.
Right.
But do you think there's a fundamental reason for that?
I think there actually is that, that lefties now,
and not always,
and I actually want to ask you about what it used to be like when there was a
sort of sane democratic party.
But if there's a fundamental reason for the anger and the outrage and the
perpetual craziness, which is they believe government is everything.
And that, you know this as a Senator, it's a pretty freaking messy,
probably often miserable game that you have to play you to be,
to be a politician in America or probably anywhere.
And that because their whole world view is through politics as opposed to a
religious or some other spiritual worldview. Well, of course,
you're going to be endlessly miserable. Do you think I'm,
ball-parking something there?
So I do. And, and it's, you know, it's interesting.
I was talking the other night to a gentlemen,
he and his wife came from Cuba and came from Cuba, flat under,
under Castro. And he was talking about, he said, you know, Ted,
you talk about the constitution quite a bit. And he said,
I think there are a lot of people like me, who,
who came from countries with constitution was meaningless and they don't
necessarily understand why that matters.
And that they're a little bit skeptical of what,
why should the constitution make a difference?
And I was agreeing with him in that we need to explain that more
government power,
the history of humanity is largely a history of government
oppressing the people. Now you need some government, I'm not an anarchist.
You need government to, to protect your,
your fundamental rights to life. To Liberty, to property. John Locke wrote,
wrote about the, the fundamental natural rights.
You need government to impose rule of law.
And we see countries that don't have that are disasters,
but the more power government has the less Liberty you have.
Jefferson had a great way of putting it.
He described the constitution as chains to bind the
mischief of government. Um, you look at the first amendment,
free speech
is not about silencing those who disagree with you. Um,
religious Liberty. It's not about forcing everyone to practice your faith.
It's about saying, look, it's up to you. What faith you practice or not at all.
That's,
that's that right of conscious that you get to decide that it's not government
that comes in, you know, you just had, all right.
You know, you talked about abortion. You, you and I may disagree on abortion,
but you just had Joe Biden a week ago. Say if he's elected,
he's coming after the little sisters of the poor.
No, I'm completely against that, by the way. I mean, I've done videos on it.
Yeah.
I mean, that is an extreme view.
You literally have politicians saying those Catholic nuns,
I'm going to go after them and force them to, uh,
pay for abortion inducing drugs.
And these are nuns who have taken vows of poverty or helping the poor and the
sick and the needy and,
and government now for years has been persecuting
them because must conform. And it's just look,
I think being libertarian and live and let live, giving people like
re roofs, respecting diversity,
solves a lot of the problems we have in the country.
So, so speaking of diversity then,
do you ever feel it because you mentioned your father and your family's story
because you're a Republican because you're on the right. That in many ways,
the people who love to scream about diversity all day long,
they've sort of stolen that from you. I know you don't waive it as a,
as a victim card, but your own personal family story. And because you're,
you're, you look white, so to speak and because you're on the right, you're,
you're just a white guy. Congratulations.
Look, I, on social media, it is amazing. You look at some of the,
some of the angry protestors who sometimes
are Angley angry,
rich white guys who were telling everyone look,
the riots that occurred following the horrific killing of George Floyd.
Many of the neighborhoods that were burned down were African-American
neighborhoods.
Some of the most poignant and powerful videos were of residents.
They're crying, going, okay. You just burned my only grocery store. You know,
my key, you know,
African-American small business owners whose whose stores were destroyed and
destroyed by
self-entitled often middle or upper
class kids.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, check out our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.